they called themselves
the autocrat the aristocrat
the acrobat and the scribe
we actually don't know too much about them
the name of the scribe we do know, and she was
Helen Augusta Whittier
and she grew up in Lowell Massachusetts
she and a group of her friends
set out one day in July of 1891
from Rose Warf in Boston and from there
they were met by a
a man they called
William the Swedish lobstermen
and he took them out to Great Brewster Island
where they set up housekeeping
so the album itself is really a wonderful
celebration and commemoration of this trip
just you open it up and you feel is if
you can hear the fog horn and smell the sea
and it's very very evocative.
Now, this volume came to our attention through
John Stilgoe who's a professor at Harvard in
the department of visual and environmental
studies.
Doctor Stilgoe was interested in the volume
because he's very interested in the built
and natural environment of the seashore and
how people interacted with those environments
and
particularly many of his students were interested
in how women interacted with the built
and natural environment along the coast and
this was a perfect example of that.
There's a wonderful passage in the book here
where they're coming back from a walk
'turning to descend this steep bluff
we see before us our own beloved Brewster
stretching out a friendly arm towards the
narrows
to bear aloft a torch for the incoming ships
when night envelopes all in darkness.'
I don't know, it makes me think that when we
go on vacations we should be doing something
like this. I go to an island in Maine in the
summer and
every summer I think
well I should be encapsulating this too and
making little drawings and photographs
and I think
historians in the future will be much the
poorer if we don't.